-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're
all doing well tonight.
Now let's get to the news.
Democrat Eric Adams defeated
Republican Curtis Sliwa
yesterday in New York City's
mayoral election.
Adams will take office
on January 1st,
which means, on January 2nd,
cab drivers will start
blaming him for traffic.
[ Laughter ]
"You believe this?
Freakin' Adams."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
returned early this morning
to Washington
from his trip to Europe.
And now he won't stop calling
the White House his flat.
[ Laughter ]
Yesterday's New Jersey
gubernatorial race
between Democratic governor
Phil Murphy
and Republican Jack Ciatterelli
remains too close to call.
In fact, as of our taping time,
both candidates were yelling,
"You take it!
No, you take it!"
[ Laughter ]
House speaker Nancy Pelosi
told reporters yesterday
that while she did not announce
a vote for President Biden's
$1.75 trillion economic agenda,
she believes disputes around it
could be resolved
by the end of the day.
Okay, it could.
But will it?
I feel like we've been waiting
around for this budget bill
for longer than we've been
waiting for "Avatar 2."
[ Laughter ]
Build Back Better is basically
Biden's unobtainium.
[ Laughter ]
And if you don't get that joke,
it's because we've be waiting
forever for "Avatar 2."
[ Laughter ]
Unobtainium jokes used to land.
Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer said yesterday
that lawmakers
have reached a deal
to lower prescription-drug
prices for seniors.
So, now they just need
to draft it up, print it out,
and send it to Joe's desk
for approval.
Nope, wrong Joe.
Oh, there we go.
[ Audience groans ]
New York mayor --
[ Laughter ]
[ Loud groan ]
New York mayor Bill de Blasio
suggested in an interview
yesterday that he is running
for governor after years
of running from governor.
[ Laughter ]
McDonald's, this year,
is celebrating
the 40th anniversary
of its McRib sandwich.
But, if anyone asks,
it was made today.
[ Laughter ]
Reality star Kendall Jenner
turned 26 today
even though her mom specifically
asked her not to.
"25 plays better."
[ Laughter ]
A new study suggests
that married couples
who met on dating apps
have a higher chance
of getting a divorce.
"Well, that was kind of
the point," said a couple
who met on "Divorcr."
[ Laughter ]
97-year-old Vito Perillo
was re-elected mayor yesterday
of a town in New Jersey
because he, once again,
failed to break
the witch's curse.
[ Laughter ]
After the --
After the
"Pirates of the Caribbean" ride
at Disneyland malfunctioned
on Sunday,
guests had to wait 90 minutes
until employees
were able to push their boats
to the exit.
"We were sitting there
for what felt like hours,
and nothing was happening,"
said someone watching the movie.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh!
Dunkin' --
[ Laughs ]
A very -- a very late zing.
[ Laughter ]
"Pirates of the --"
[ Laughing ]
Those filmmakers were like,
"I think
we're out of the woods."
[ Laughter ]
"Been over a decade."
"Well, at least they're not
going after 'Avatar.'
They are?"
[ Laughter ]
Dunkin' Donuts announced
new flavors this week
for their holiday lineup,
including a toasted
white-chocolate signature latte
and white mocha hot chocolate.
And if you want to see
what those drinks look like,
check out Ben Affleck's
paparazzi photos next week.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, the animal rights group
PETA last week called on
Major League Baseball
to stop using the term bullpen
for the area
where pitchers warm up
because it references the place
where cattle
are kept before slaughter.
Instead, they suggested
using the more
animal-friendly term "arm barn."
[ Laughter ]
That one got the most attention,
but there are several other
animal-themed terms PETA
would like to see changed.
For example --
We're gonna do some now.
[ Laughter ]
That's what
this whole bit's gonna be.
For example --
[ Laughter ]
The --
[ Laughs ]
The supermarket chain
Piggly Wiggly
is offensive to pigs,
as pigs do not have hips
that are conducive to wiggling,
so...
[ Laughter ]
...they suggested
changing the store's name
to Broccoli Woccoli.
[ Laughter ]
Having ants in your pants
would be
an uncomfortable sensation
for a human.
But just imagine how cruel --
how cruel an experience
for the ant.
[ Laughter ]
Especially in a corduroy
or rigid denim.
[ Laughter ]
So, next time you're
feeling anxious or restless,
may we suggest the term
"beans in your jeans"?
[ Laughter ]
If you're at a party,
and it's all dudes,
rather than
triggering vegetarians
and people suffering
from hypertension
by calling it a "sausage fest,"
they suggest a call it
something less offensive,
like a "Boner-roo Teste-val."
[ Laughter ]
And they appreciate that's --
that's a mouthful.
[ Laughter ]
Moving on,
nature's greatest pollinators
have six sections to their legs
and don't appreciate you
patella-fetishists
focusing on just the one,
so stop calling something neat
the "bee's knees"
and instead say
it's the yam's gams.
[ Laughter ]
And I know that's hard
for all of you
who are still saying
the bee's knees.
[ Laughter ]
Up next, instead of saying
"like a fish out of water"
and invoking
the horror of suffocation
to our scaly cousins,
say "like a vaccinated person
in the fire department."
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
And...
[ Laughter ]
Instead of saying "Larry Bird,"
which could cause a sparrow
to turn and say "What?"
before plowing into a window,
say "Danny Ainge."
[ Light laughter ]
Keep that one for the "best of."
[ Laughter ]
Next up --
[ Laughs ]
We're only -- Wait.
We're only a tenth of the way
through this?
[ Laughter ]
Next, instead of saying,
"He sleeps with the fishes,"
which is straight-up
slut shaming, he said --
say, "He caught COVID
from an unvaccinated fireman."
[ Laughter ]
And instead of saying,
"He's no spring chicken,"
needlessly reminding the birds
of their inescapable mortality,
say, "He looking like
an heirloom gourd."
[ Laughter ]
Moving on --
Moving on, instead of saying
"There's plenty of fish
in the sea," which ignores
the devastating effects
of commercial overfishing,
say, "Look, Linda,
you had to have known
this was a real possibility
when your fireman boyfriend
decided not to get vaccinated."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, when it's time
for the talk, rather than
teaching your children
about the birds and bees,
whose sex lives
are nobody's damn business
but their own,
teach them about the zucchini
and the pumpkin
with a hole carved into it.
[ Laughter ]
This has been other
animal-themed terms.
I told you it was a bit.
PETA would like to see change.